بعيدًا عن الخطوط الأمامية
، يبدأ جيش من الفنانين عملية
إصلاح حزن هذه الأمة ،
ويقوم بإصلاح القطيع الناجم عن
الحرب
في الأوبرا الوطنية ، كل شخص لديه
دور يلعبه
الليلة سيكون باليه جيزيل
أول أداء كامل منذ أن
أغلق المسرح أبوابه.
منذ ما يقرب من شهرين ،
بينما كان الموسيقيون ينفضون الغبار
عن آلاتهم ، وعندما بدأ الجمهور يتدفق حتى
نأتي إلى المسرح ،
نعود إلى جزء صغير من حياتنا
الذي كان موجودًا قبل الحرب ، حيث نزحنا
داخليًا من الكهوف ، كما تقول
جوليا ديميتريفا.  للمجيء إلى
المنافسة أثناء وجود أعمال عدائية
، يخبرني المدير الفني لماذا
قرروا الانفتاح الآن ،
نحن نفهم أن الضوء يجب أن يهزم
الظلام وأن الحياة يجب أن تهزم الموت
ومهمة المسرح هي تأكيد
ذلك
ولكن تذكيرات الحرب ليست كذلك أبدًا.
بعيدًا ضيوفنا الأعزاء ، سيتم
تعليق فعاليتنا في حالة إنذار الغارة الجوية ،
لم يُسمح إلا ببيع 300 مقعدًا
الليلة بسعة o  لا يزال ملجأ بيرا من المتفجرات
يتم بيعه ، لم يستغرق
الأمر سوى دقائق حتى تفتح الستارة
ويمكنك أن
تشعر بالتوتر لأن هذا الأداء
خاص للغاية
[موسيقى]
لبضع ساعات ، لا شيء آخر يهم
مثل الجمهور وأنا يتم نقلي إلى
عالم من الحب و  جمال
[موسيقى]
عزف جيزيل الليلة في ساحة تبلغ من العمر 21 عامًا
إنه شعور رائع أنها تخبرني مرة أخرى في
غرفة ملابسها
لأن الرقص يساعد على تشتيت الانتباه
عما يحدث
مثل العديد من الناس هنا التي اهتزت حياتها بسبب
الحرب وأهوال البوتشا
حيث تم العثور مؤخرًا على مقابر جماعية
، نجت أمي وجدتي وأختها
من العمل في جزار ، أخبرتني
الآن أنها في أمان في بولندا تستعيد
أعصابها ،
تجد دورينا العزاء في هذه المرحلة
[موسيقى]
كل المشاعر السلبية التي
تتراكم لفترة طويلة تتدفق
أخبرتني بأداء شافي لكل من
داخل وخارج المسرح ،
مما يوفر الراحة لأولئك الذين هم في أمس الحاجة إليها
على أمل أن يتمكنوا من رفعها ولو
لفترة وجيزة فقط  روح هذه
الأمة المؤلمة عيسى سواريز في أوكرانيا